- Hope everyone had a great Thanksgiving.
Thanks for joining us today.
Hope your AWS re:Invent
is off to a great start.
I have the pleasure today of
having Sathwik from ServiceNow
and Jamie from SLB,
they're formerly called
Schlumberger, with us today.
But before we get to the
panel session, just wanna go
through the agenda.
I'm just gonna give a quick overview
of what we're seeing in the market today.
Then talk about the
NVIDIA-AWS partnership.
Just tell you what DGX Cloud is.
Have any of you heard what DGX Cloud is?
NVIDIA DGX Cloud?
Okay, cool, so I'll explain what that is,
and Sathwik and Jamie will be here to kind
of talk about their experience
with DGX Cloud, NVIDIA AI on AWS,
and we'll have a little bit of maybe time
to do some informal Q&A.
This isn't quite the right setup for that,
but we'll see what we could do.
Okay, so AI adoption is everywhere.
Is everyone already doing some sort
of AI, like either developing
or already implementing AI today?
Hands, all right, cool.
Looks like the majority.
So, this is really a new
industrial revolution
where it's powered by AI factories.
And what we're here to do is talk
about AI factories in the Cloud.
And AWS really is one
of the biggest AI factories
that you could use.
And you could see it spans
across all industries.
And today, we're gonna be talking
about two very distinct
industries, and they'll talk
about their exciting use
cases on how they're using AI
and how the AI factory
and DGX Cloud is helping
them develop their AI.
So there's...
What we're seeing is,
we're seeing the emergence
of three scaling laws for AI.
We really started with
pre-training scaling,
which is really teaching a
model from the internet, right?
So if you think about
surfing the internet,
you could get a lot of
information that way,
but then you wanna take
it to the next level.
That's just consuming the
data that you're seeing.
But then you wanna think about it.
So, like when we go to
post-training scaling,
this is really where the
model goes to school,
and it learns thinking, right?
And then, kind of the last
part is really the idea
of reasoning.
And so we call this test-time scaling.
So this is a long thinking.
It's not just thinking
of like what answer it's gonna
give back, but it's thinking
before it gives back the answer,
and reasons to see if
that's the best response
to give back to you.
And as the intelligence
of the model increases,
there's a higher demand for compute.
And so, this is where the AI factory,
especially AI factory in the Cloud,
where you could scale out as
your AI projects get bigger.
You could scale that very easily.
And I think everyone is,
when they think of NVIDIA,
they think about
infrastructure and NVIDIA GPUs.
It's actually the full-Stack
that really makes all this happen.
It's the software layer on up.
I'll show you in the next slide,
but I wanted to talk
about, we're integrated
with AWS in our partnership.
So from CUDA Libraries, if
you're familiar with those,
having those available in AWS.
But it's also the full platforms
that we have available in
AWS, like in the Marketplace.
So anywhere from DGX Cloud,
which I'll talk about in the next slide.
NVIDIA AI Enterprise, which
is our Enterprise AI suite
of software, Omniverse,
if you've heard of that.
We have NVIDIA NIM, which
are inference microservices.
And there's other sessions
that NVIDIA has here
that we'll go a little
bit deeper into that.
And then not only that, but
all our libraries are software.
They're integrated into
various AWS services,
so you could consume them throughout AWS,
and kind of all this is
built upon the infrastructure
that you know, and you're familiar with,
which are the NVIDIA GPUs and networking.
Okay, so DGX Cloud, what we've done
with DGX Cloud is NVIDIA
looked at what are...
What's the kind of AI factory
or infrastructure that NVIDIA needs
to accomplish our own AI goals?
And so, we reached out to, you know,
one of our biggest
partners, like AWS, to say,
"Let's co-engineer this
because NVIDIA had some requirements.
AWS has technology.
How do we co-engineer this
and marry the best of the
technologies together?"
So we start with the infrastructure.
If you look at GB200's, the latest,
I know B300 was announced
not too long ago.
So, keep an eye out on what's available,
and what may be coming next.
But there's high-performance networking
and also Lustre storage.
So that's at the infrastructure layer.
And then we optimize EKS on DGX Cloud.
So from an infrastructure
management standpoint,
that's optimized as well.
We take it to another level,
and we've included Run.ai.
Has anyone heard about
Run:ai GPU Orchestration?
So the idea here is, you
have high-performance GPUs
that you know, you're
paying some money for,
and you wanna make sure that
those GPUs are fully optimized.
You're getting the most out
of what you're paying for.
So Run:ai will really help you
use the GPUs effectively.
I know Sathwik has a testimony on that.
So, it'll be exciting to hear from him
on how he's used Run:ai and
enterprise-grade software.
So, a lot of the AI software
you may be using is open source,
but there may become a time,
where you're gonna roll
out your AI application
into production.
So you want something
that's enterprise-grade
that's supported, has very
set-like production branching
and releases.
And so, we offer that with DGX Cloud.
And then, kind of, lastly,
is really access to NVIDIA AI
and Cloud experts.
So in this DGX Cloud service,
we provide technical account managers
and 24-by-7 Enterprise Support.
And then, all this translates into is
that you have a platform that provides
the best of NVIDIA AI and
an optimized full-Stack
that's on co-engineered infrastructure.
Okay, and so now that
you have the background
on where NVIDIA sees the
market is, what DGX Cloud is,
I want to introduce our spotlight panel.
So, I'll let you guys introduce yourself,
and maybe we start with who
are you, who's your company,
and what do you do for them?
So, I'll start with Sathwik.
- Okay, sounds good.
Yeah, that's me up on
the screen on top of one
with me. (laughs)
But how many of you have heard
of ServiceNow?
Quick Show fans?
Okay, everybody knows.
So I am a Principal
Scientist at ServiceNow.
I lead the Foundation Model Lab,
and my team is responsible
for the mid-training and
the post-training of models.
We try to train, like,
or actually, we train
really small language models
that are on par with most
of the frontier models.
And our goal is to be able to
service all of the workloads
that we see on a day-to-day basis.
Yeah, so I think that's what
I do at a high level, so.
- Hi, everybody, my name's Jamie.
I'm gonna ask the same question
and expect fewer hands.
Who's heard of SLB?
Well, there's some at least, that's good.
So we are a technology company
in the energy industry.
We're one
of the world's largest oil
and gas service companies,
but we also have a substantial
new energy business as well.
So we deal with the full
spectrum of the energy business.
Everything from producing
oil and glass globally,
we operate in over 120 countries,
as well as helping people
with their new energy needs.
And our goal really is to
enable people to produce energy,
the growing energy demand of the planet,
but safely and cleanly over time.
Now, our business is divided
up into different divisions.
Some of those visions are
heavy industrial divisions doing things
like drilling wells, managing production.
But we also have a digital
division, which is where I work,
where we produce technology
that can help us and our customers
who are typically the large
energy companies' plan,
produce models, simulations,
as well as operate responsibly
and very sort of efficiently.
Most of our business is
science and engineering.
So it's a heavily vertical business.
So everybody, you know, a lot
of people in our business,
you know, are very specialist scientists
or engineers and the different divisions.
They might have even gone
to different departments
at universities.
And so, ours is not really a
very transactional business.
It's a sort of high-science business.
And so, we are using AI to try
and augment the workforce
that does this very important work,
especially as perhaps
there's less people coming
into the industry these days.
My role as the Business Line Director is
to provide our internal
data and AI platform.
We use that to power our
own TurnKey applications
that we sell to our customers.
And we also sell the
platform itself directly
to our customers to help
them do their business.
- Energy is really in the spotlight,
especially with building
out all these data centers
and AI factories, so. (laughs)
- Yeah, yeah, sometimes
they say, you know, to do AI
for energy, which is what we need, we have
to have energy for AI.
- Yeah.
- It's a kind of bit of a,
hopefully, a virtuous circle,
but it's kind of interesting that many
of our customers are
really in the business
of providing energy for AI as well.
So it's become an increasingly
important concern.
- All right, so what are
your goals in developing AI?
So you're here, you're using DGX Cloud,
but before we get into
the DGX Cloud part, what,
like before you needed
something like DGX Cloud, what,
like what were your goals?
Like, what did you set
forth to say, "Okay, this is
what I need to do, this is
the AI we're developing."
And because of that then you had to look
for the infrastructure.
So, could you just share
a little bit of, you know,
what your goals for developing AI?
- Yeah, sounds good.
So I guess everybody's
familiar with ServiceNow,
but just to recap a little bit,
ServiceNow is basically
an enterprise company
that hosts most of your, maybe IT, SM,
ITOM, ITAM, CSM, HR, Legal Compliance,
whatever kind of data.
There's tons of processes
that perhaps nobody
wants to do these days.
Everybody's trying to automate it.
Maybe 15, 20 years ago, you
know, the trend was that,
"Hey, let's code up some
workflows and get it working."
And then with traditional
machine learning,
it kind of changed,
like smarter workflows.
So at this point, it's like
Agentic, AI applications
that are running a lot of these use cases.
A really cool way to think about it.
So, Anthropic introduced this
concept about MCP, right?
- Yeah.
- So,
you just have like this huge list of tools
and functions that you can call,
and if a person were to sit
there calling the right tools
and functions in the right order,
you could accomplish just about any task.
The challenge with
models is really twofold.
One is, will they be able
to accomplish the task?
And the second one is the cost, right?
So if you try to use a
frontier model for this,
maybe GPT-5.1, or maybe GPT-6,
whenever it comes out, (chuckles)
I'm sure it's gonna do a really great job.
But then, it's not really practical
because if you start using, you know,
the most expensive model
for every single use case,
for every single employee,
like, I don't know,
I'm here in Vegas trying
to book a whole trip,
and then I just go ask the
system to do this for me,
it's gonna start costing a lot more
than actually having people do this job.
So you need to really build
efficient Agentic systems,
at the same time,
make sure the models are efficient.
So the goal of, at least my team, is
to build really powerful foundation models
that can power most of the use cases
across the ServiceNow platform.
And so that the customers
can enjoy the same level
of performance as a frontier model,
but not really be bogged
down by the costs.
- Yep.
- And what we try to do is,
inspired by the use cases,
design some custom post-training recipes,
but at a high level,
our model is not really any
different from a DeepSeek,
or a Quinn, or any other model.
We also open-source most of our models
so that anybody can use it.
But yeah, that's at a high level
what we're trying to accomplish.
And DGX and AWS makes
it a whole lot easier.
Maybe we can get into that.
- Yeah.
And, Jamie, how are you guys?
Like, what were your goals
or what are your goals?
- Yeah, yeah, well, our
business is kind of interesting.
How it works is
that we, very expensively,
acquire vast amounts of data.
And we'll show you later on what some
of that data looks like.
Seismic data, geophysical data,
so we conduct surveys in the
field to explore for data.
And seismic is where we shoot
very large geographic areas
of data to try and characterize
what's underground.
'Cause if we want to lift oil and gas,
or if we want to sequester carbon,
we need to understand
what's going on underground.
We can't do that, so we have
to build models based on
very large volumes of data.
Similarly, we sometimes wanna
know a bit more specific
about a particular area.
And so we'll drill a well bore,
and get petrophysical data
about the actual structure
of the layer cake, the
formations that sit underground.
And with that information,
geologists and geophysicists
can build models, if you like,
architectural drawings of
what's going on underground.
And there's a lot of
uncertainty in those models.
And so for maybe 30 or 40 years,
we've been using various techniques
from complex deterministic physics
and mathematics to be able
to predict the structure
of the subsurface and its behavior,
and simulate the flow
of fluids in the porous
media, that is the rocks.
But over time,
we've been using more
data-driven techniques.
We've been using specific models,
machine learning, and things like that.
And obviously, in the last few years,
we've seen there's a great opportunity
to use more general-purpose
foundational models,
But we are not really in the business
of just going from text
to text like coding
or even for process automation.
We need to be able to synthesize
and generate responses,
synthetic responses,
from the subsurface.
So we use foundation models for seismic
and time series data,
and for petrophysical
data that would allow us
to predict scientific responses
as if we'd acquired the data directly.
So we call these the
main foundation models,
and that's what we've been
using the technology for.
And ultimately, we expect to combine those
with the other forms
of data-driven modeling
and physics-based modeling,
and then the orchestration
that you are talking about in
the agentic world to be able
to provide assistance to geologists,
geoscientist engineers that are a bit
like the coding assistance
that you would get
in your regular world.
But we've gotta bring all
of these pieces together
for it to make sense.
- Yeah.
So kind of two key themes, you know,
building models, Agentic AI.
How many of you in the
audience are building models?
Like, are you training fine-tuning models?
Okay, cool.
And then, how many are creating AI agents?
Oh, quite a few, okay.
Cool, that's awesome.
And so, you know, we talked
about DGX Cloud as kind
of like this TurnKey, you
know, full-Stack platform.
How did DGX Cloud on AWS help you achieve
those goals that you set out
to do that you guys just,
you know, described?
- Yeah, makes sense.
I'll maybe like give a high-level first,
and then we can go into the details more.
- Right.
- I think prior to us
using DGX Cloud on AWS,
we obviously bought a bunch
of hardware from NVIDIA.
- Yeah.
- And installed it in-house,
had our own orchestration frameworks,
job management, et cetera.
I think, I mean, it was
great, but obviously,
like maintaining extremely
large clusters is
a full-time job.
And we decided to like
switch to something that DGX
and AWS offers, just because
it's like maybe more reliable.
And also, I think if you
buy hardware, you're stuck
to using it for a while, right?
So we can keep switching
out newer hardware
when it's available.
And on top of this, I think one
of your older slides
captured it perfectly.
The cluster that we are using
right now comes with Lustre,
comes with Run:ai.
- Yep, go back to that slide just so...
- Yeah, so it comes with
Luster, comes with Run:ai,
obviously, networking is super important
because we don't wanna be
wasting any time at all.
So, I think these are super important.
One reason, at least, why we
really, really like Run:ai
to the point where we don't wanna use
a cluster without it is
because we wanna maximize
the cluster usage as much as possible.
And earlier, we used to like come up
with custom job schedulers that try
to like use the compute
whenever there's downtime.
I think this is made
super easy with Run:ai
because of the way we can prioritize jobs,
and stuff like that, so...
We are able to get almost
like 100% utilization
either with training models
or synthesizing data or evaluating.
So, I think along with this, obviously,
we've had like over the last year or so,
close to like zero downtime,
like maybe a few hours on one day
when you guys were upgrading the cluster.
(Charlie laughs)
But I think that's what
is really important
because you can't afford to lose any time.
- Yep, and then, I can't
remember if I mentioned,
but if you wanna use Run:ai,
so all of this we made
available through AWS.
You don't have to use this
specifically in DGX Cloud.
So all of this is available
through the AWS Marketplace.
So you could kind of mix
and match, like what,
you know, this Stack,
but know that everything's
really optimized together.
So I just kind of
summarized it in this slide
what Sathwik just talked
about, what he just shared.
But turning to you, Jamie,
how did you guys use, you
know, NVIDIA DGX Cloud
and AWS to accomplish your goals
that you just described to us?
- Yeah, yeah, so we've
got a long relationship,
and we've often had quite a lot
of in-house infrastructure
for running HPC workflows
for simulation and seismic processing.
So we kind of start off with
having some infrastructure,
and when we were building
and training these models,
we had some, 100 infrastructure
that we ran locally
that kind of got us off
the ground, I suppose.
But then, the world's moving
very quickly, you know,
and we've just done two major
project product releases,
Generative AI and Agentic
Assistant in the last two years.
And so, given how quickly
the world was moving,
we decided to leverage
our relationship with AWS
and within NVIDIA to use
DGX Cloud to bring stuff
to market much quicker
than we would've done
if we were just using
our own infrastructure.
So we were really able to
accelerate the development
of these models, these
domain-specific models,
by using this TurnKey Stack
where everything worked
beautifully out of the box.
The team was able to work
on what mattered to them,
and then we were able to depend
on the performance quality
and support that we got,
and the ability to not have
to purchase some, you know,
new hardware and everything else used
in the elastic compute capability of AWS
along with that
beautifully optimized Stack
to really let us focus on
producing these domain models.
And we were able to make
great progress, you know?
And then we were able to
partner, DGX Cloud was able
to be optimized through
the support that we had
to get increases in throughput
from the same hardware
as we moved from a 2D
model to a two-and-a-half-D
to a 3D model for the
Seismic Foundation model.
So, really, it's been a
brilliant support for us
as we are trying to bring
products to market quickly
and not having to worry
about the infrastructure,
and being able to tap into
the AWS and DGX Cloud.
- Okay, great.
Sathwik, you are talking
about your, you know,
the Apriel models.
How do the models, like the models
that you're building,
tell us a little bit more about Apriel,
you know, family models,
and how it plays into
ServiceNow's overall strategy,
and kind of portfolio offering.
- Yeah, so we've been
training models for about two,
two-and-a-half years now.
And we decided to
open-source all the models
that we train starting this year, Jan,
just because it brings more awareness
about what we are doing.
And also, at the same time,
the model by itself can't do much
without all the agentic orchestrators
and the tools, and the
data, and whatnot, right?
So, and this year,
we've done three model releases so far.
There was a 5-billion-parameter
model that we trained,
and then we trained a
15-billion-parameter reasoning model.
And then we also upgraded
the same 15-billion-parameter
reasoning model,
which is like a multimodal model.
It consumes images,
texts, and outputs text.
And our goal here is
obviously not to compete
with Frontier Labs.
It's really about how can we build
Frontier-level reasoning performance
on a single GPU scale, right?
Because if I can have a
very small model that's able
to do like the most complex tasks,
it means that I can service a large amount
of workloads without spending a lot.
And this will really allow us,
allow our customers to
like pick and choose.
Like, if they have the
most complex use cases,
they can reserve all of the,
whatever OpenAI cloud credits
for those kind of tasks,
and then just be able to
default to like our models
for most of the other use cases.
- Yeah.
- So if we look at a couple
of slides further down.
- Oh, yeah.
- Yeah, so this is from
a model that we released,
like maybe a couple of months ago,
maybe one-and-a-half months ago.
Our model is highlighted in the red box.
If you can see, it's kind
of on par with DeepSeek R1,
and you know, Gemini Flash.
And for, you know, just talking
about how big our model is,
we are at 15-billion-parameter scale.
DeepSeek R1 is about 600 billion.
And then Quinn is about, you know,
you see it's about like 235 billion.
I don't know how big Gemini
Flash is, honestly. (laughs)
But our model is like kind
of on par with a model
that's like 30 times larger than its size.
And the open-source community
also seems to love it
because we got like close
to 100,000 downloads.
People are using it, and
we bring the same model
into production, so people
can actually leverage it
for whatever use cases they might have.
- Awesome.
- Yeah.
- Great.
Jamie, you mentioned, you
know, as we're prepping,
there's some unique
challenges that you guys faced
as you were, you know, training
and developing your AI.
Do you wanna share a little
bit about those challenges
because-
- Yeah-
- Some folks in the audience
might be facing similar one-
- So, maybe we go forward to the slide
that has some of the Seismic on there.
So it's very important for
us, as I said earlier on,
that our...
What we are doing here is introducing
generative AI technology into a portfolio
of existing technology.
A bit like the tools that
you have in, you know,
the MCP tools that you have in ServiceNow.
So we will have physics-based
simulators, algorithms,
we'll have machine learning-type models
for doing things like automating fault
and horizon interpretation
that can take months
and months and months.
And so we saw an
opportunity here to be able
to build what's effectively
a multimodal model
that's specific for our industry
that would really accelerate
the work of the people.
So, you know, we do another
example where we have data
that we want to bring into one
of our traditional applications,
but there's some gaps in the data
because the acquisition wasn't clean
or the processing wasn't clean.
And we can call down on this model,
what would normally
have taken weeks or days
or even months sometimes
to reconstruct the
missing data with a human.
We can actually just call on
an agent now to reconstruct
that missing data within
certain constraints
and really accelerate a workflow
and give a really complete
picture of the Earth.
And as you can see here, this
is not just generating text,
it's text to images, images to text,
and ultimately to models.
So, really, this technology for us is
very non-transactional.
It's an almost creative
process that we're trying
to support here amongst scientists.
And really importantly for us,
this has to sit in their
portfolio of tools,
and we have to produce something
that's good enough for
them to trust, right?
You know, with all of their
Ph.D. years of experience,
this tool has to sit along with them
and say, "I can use this assistant
because I know it's been
trained on the data,
I know I can trust the
people that have trained it."
And so, we started off
training it with public data,
and that produced a certain
level of capability.
And now, we've started augmenting that
with proprietary data
from our own acquisitions.
And then, I think one of the things
that's really interesting from
us is that we'll be working
with our customers for that trust thing.
They need to train it and fine-tune it
with their own data as well.
So that's a kind of unique
thing in our business,
is that every one of our major
customers will either take
the off-the-shelf model,
but more likely, they'll combine that
with their own data as well.
So they'll have their
own fine-tuned model.
So, that represents the basins
and the geological settings
that they operate within
to build that trust
that it will provide accurate predictions.
- So, in both your cases, then,
you're offering these models
for your customers to kind
of fine-tune it and kind of
include some of their data
to add the intelligence to it.
So, are you seeing more
customers doing fine-tuning
or doing like a RAG?
Like does everyone
understand what RAG is, what,
or are you familiar what RAG is?
Retrieval Augmented Generation.
Okay, it's basically taking a model
and then going out
to retrieve additional data
from like a vector database
to supplement the knowledge
of the foundation model.
So, are you guys seeing more
like customers taking your model
and then fine-tuning
it or doing like a RAG?
- So, for us, we are not in
the business, as you said,
of building general purpose, you know,
foundational frontier models.
So when it comes to interacting
with the customer's corporate memory,
they don't take ChatGPT and fine-tune it
by sticking their documents in it.
They'll use a RAG-type approach for that.
So the data in the AI platform
that we produce will often
go back through decades
of old documents and
report from the '50s, '60s,
sometimes even back
to the 19th century,
that shows the early days
of oil field expiration.
It's kind of funny if you
read these documents, right?
'Cause the language has
changed a lot over 100 years.
And then what we'll do is
when we ingest that data,
we have to use fancy
techniques for the OCR-ing
of the old data, right?
To capture the semantic
meaning of those old documents.
We'll create pipelines to ingest
that into the environment,
and then automatically vectorize it
so that we have out-the-box
RAG going along.
But then, in the case of
these specialty domains,
petrophysics, geophysics, seismic data,
then we'll actually fine-tune it.
So, texts, reports, documents,
RAG, proper scientific output models,
we'll use the domain foundation
models to create an edge.
- Yeah, I think it's a
little different for us.
If you roll back a couple of slides,
I think you had a nice illustration, yeah,
of how the entire Stack looks like.
So you have like a whole
bunch of documents.
You have like policies,
triggers, tools, whatever else.
And then the large language model is
just a small part of the whole, you know-
- [Charlie] Yeah.
- Whole thing.
So what ends up happening is,
for the most part, when
people start using our system,
it works because,
I mean, how different can, I don't know,
like one customer's
flight ordering, you know,
like flight booking
versus like whatever
food ordering system be
from another customer, right?
So the reason why it gets
complex between customer
to customer is because
they have different ways
of implementing their own policies,
and sometimes the model
just does not understand
what it's doing.
So ServiceNow actually allows people
to customize the agentic, you know,
the agentic scaffolding.
- Yeah.
- You can have custom policies defined,
you can have guardrails.
And for the most part,
we see that this works.
And I mean, if there are
enough customers asking
for custom models, maybe
that's gonna be a thing.
But yeah, I think it's for
the most part not necessary.
- Okay, great.
Then, like, where do
you guys go from here?
So, how will you move
forward with your projects
after using DGX Cloud on AWS?
So kind of what's next?
Like you have your model,
how are you gonna kind
of deploy, are you gonna
come back to DGX Cloud?
Are you gonna use AWS
infrastructure service,
a mix of on-prem?
Like, what's next for you guys?
- Yeah, I think from what
I can definitely say,
I mean, you think about NVIDIA,
and then it's like, you know,
you guys are a pioneer in AI,
think about AWS, it's, you know, arguably,
one of the best clouds in the world.
So you don't wanna let go of both.
You wanna have both
(laughs) of them combined
in the right manner, so to say.
But, I think, you know,
DGX has been super useful,
and at the same time, DGX
has been hosted on AWS,
and we've seen that it's super reliable,
scalable, quick, and I think we'd hope
to like continue with the same thing.
But at the same time, like
you said, Run:ai is on AWS,
you know, Lustre is from AWS,
there is existing
infrastructure that would
obviously encourage us to
explore that option, too.
I think, you know,
ideally, we want both, but-
- Yeah, awesome.
- Yeah, I think for us, DGX Cloud
and our partnership with AWS
and NVIDIA was fantastic for that kind
of early-stage product development.
It's given them, us, the
velocity that we needed.
I think when it comes to
us scaling out globally,
we'll use a variety of techniques.
Some customers are so sensitive
about their proprietary data
that they're gonna wanna deal
with that on-prem, right?
So, you know, we do that.
Similarly, we offer a lot of services
as a SaaS to a global market.
So we'll be able to leverage
the commodity infrastructure
and commit to, you know, the
services that you get from AWS
or other providers to be able
to deliver solutions globally.
But I think we always remind
ourselves that this is really,
we are really at the early
stages of this revolution.
You know, we're out there
talking to customers,
discovering what they need.
So something like DGX
Cloud is super important
so that we can respond to what we learn
from the customers in the market,
and then as we effectively
establish a pattern
and we wanna develop and
mature that, then we can move
towards more commodity
infrastructure as well.
But I think it's gonna be very dynamic
over the next few years to understand
where the world's going with all of this.
- Yeah.
- Especially in our industry,
because they're not just looking at it
for process automation.
In our industry, people are saying
that we want to use agents
to retire uncertainty,
to explore more options than
they would've been able to do
with their previous resourcing levels.
They want to...
They don't just wanna do RAG
on their existing corporate documents
because then their future
organization would always behave
like their past organization.
- Yeah.
- They want to kind of have a diversity
of sources coming in.
So I think it's gonna be a
really interesting period
and we're gonna need all kinds
of infrastructure support,
but definitely with the
scale that you get from AWS,
and the elastic capability,
and the kind of precision,
and beautifully integrated Stack
that you get from NVIDIA DGX.
- Yeah, it's amazing, 'cause you're saying
how like your industry
started like in the 1900s.
- Yeah, yeah.
- It seems like AI's
really like making it go fast now,
even though it's a mature market.
- And it took us 100 years to get there.
- Yeah. (laughs)
- We're celebrating 100 years, next year.
2026 is SLB's 100th anniversary.
- Yeah.
- So, yeah.
- Yeah, and I think, you know,
something we touch upon is
the NVIDIA, like full-Stack Ecosystem,
whether you're using it, you
know, on-prem, in the Cloud,
it's really portable.
So you have that flexibility,
and again, that whole
ecosystem's available on AWS,
through the Marketplace,
embedded in their services.
So that portability adds a lot of value
and flexibility to customers.
We have some time left.
I don't know if anyone has questions.
This isn't the most conducive
way of asking questions.
Does anyone have a question
you could just ask?
I could repeat it so
everyone could hear it.
If not, there's
opportunity to come to talk
to us after.
And I also, oh,
did you wanna cover this
one real quick, Jamie?
- I mean, I think this is really
just describing our journey
with DGX, and how it was
able to match our needs,
as we innovated over a two-year period.
And as we move from rudimentary models
and moved up from a sort
of 2D model to a 3D model
to be able to build.
And again, we are really
just at the beginning
of this journey, right?
- Yeah.
- But now we are starting
to get foundation models
that produce really
plausible generative results
that we can incorporate into workflows
alongside our existing machine
learning-based approaches
and our existing physics,
and you know, strict
mathematical-based approaches as well.
So these are gonna become
a very important part
of our toolkit going forward.
And you can see, you know, that we've been
through quite a steep
learning curve, and AWS
and NVIDIA have very much
supported our learning curve,
the velocity that we needed.
- Great, thank you so
much for attending today.
Really appreciate you.
Enjoy the show.